maybe you're the first gay bachelor and
we don't even know
billy eichner is sending love to colton
underwood
after coming out as gay on good morning
america wednesday
and now multiple outlets are reporting
that the former bachelor is filming his
own netflix reality show you know i
really hope that throughout all of this
you get to see
different sides of me let me get you up
to speed
back in 2019 billy appeared on colton's
season of the bachelor and said
this during a chat with the former nfl
player and the show's host
chris harrison i'm gay i know that's a
shock colton
that i think you should look into maybe
you're the first gay bachelor and we
don't even know
i i well on wednesday
the 28 year old opened up about his
sexuality for the first time publicly
i've ran for myself for a long time i've
hated myself for a long time and
i'm gay and shortly after that
the throwback clip of billy's brief
cameo went viral
and the 42 year old billy on the street
star sent his love and support to colton
sharing the clip on instagram alongside
the caption
congrats colton underwood if you're gay
be gay
i've been gay forever and i love it and
colton he took notice sliding into the
comments to write quote
love you love this now and now i love
being gay
billy's response i'm happy for you see
you at the club colton
it's been amazing and now according to
multiple reports
colton is getting his own netflix
reality show
i'm excited for that variety reports
that the show
is unscripted already in production and
follows colton
living his life publicly as a gay man
i'm emotional but i'm emotional in like
such a good happy positive way
i'm like the happiest and healthiest
i've ever been in my life and
that means the world to me of course
this all comes after colton spoke
candidly about his journey to
self-acceptance with robin roberts on
good morning america wednesday morning
i came to terms with that earlier this
year and have been processing it
and the next step in all of this was
sort of
letting people know still nervous but
yeah it's it's been a journey for sure